this is a quick video to show you how
you can possibly get your free 50 gold
bars
in games like diamond digger saga farm
hero saga and papa papa pear saga at
king.com
i'm using my friend bill's account here
he hasn't signed up for king.com so
he should be able to
get a bonus 50 gold bars
on facebook i'm going to go ahead and
log into diamond digger saga
as you can see right now we have 50 free
gold bars from when we started the game
so i'm going to go ahead and go over to
king.com
and i'm going to create a new account
for bill so that he can sync his account
i had his uh
his email address already
cut and pasted so
you put your email in the in the field
and then you hit sign up
create a new password for the account
and this is the important part
if you're eligible to sync your
your account
you'll get this pop-up here you just
need to make sure that you sync your
progress
some players are mentioning that they
aren't getting this pop-up i'm not
really sure why but um
if you get this that means you can sync
your account
and then you'll get a notification that
says the connection was success
successful
so you can go ahead and close that
you'll see you have four four games to
choose from here
i'm gonna go ahead and
load up diamond digger
and these games work exactly the same as
they do in
on facebook if you sync your account
alright so now you see we have 100 gold
bars
so that was pretty quick and easy
and you can do this for the other games
candy crush doesn't work but uh
you can get 50 gold bars and pop a pair
and farm heroes as well